welcome to this video oops oaken or
something along those slides going for
something else pelicans defense i got a
request to play that after i recently
won a game with that opening let's see
okay Bishop c4 I think it's quite it's
almost the same as played in the other
game okay let's take their that's not
such a bad structure here maybe I did
start with the capture and now attack
that you five pod point is slightly weak
there
hmm what's so easy to cover Queenie to
maybe no he decides to cheek cheek on d5
interesting yeah okay have to take with
this pawn I don't want ed 6 to happen
hmm that's an interesting decision at
least he gets in Bishop f4 now I have
two very safely protect the pond I
thought that would be the idea we should
have form it's not okay
okay maybe you will see a town looking
at this pawn down do I want Quincy form
let's try that I wouldn't mind to trade
Queens in this position okay I like the
idea of playing an endgame here with my
king um positioned in the sand down and
in general I have decent piece of Sierra
don't have a light squared Bishop
anymore for example so I don't suffer
any structural problem here it's equal
of course I'm not saying I'm better or
so um do I want to trade they're not
sure ever want
ious bishop is potentially bad so okay
this should be fate is debatable but you
can play that definitely the situation
here the position is so close that
that's no big issue okay does he want to
go with f4 maybe I was thinking of
Knight to c4 anyway or a 40 kg 6g for
age 5 f-5 is this coming maybe but they
have to do the sea anyway h 5 f-5 maybe
nets tricky a 5 is coming rather quickly
I can opine d7 though I don't think it's
that bad
hmm yeah strange position but I don't
think it's particularly bad for me King
is protecting e6 and I have roped g8
coming with tempo the e5 pawn is
something that he has to think about
whenever he pushes f5 this pawn might
become weak I note that i still have
very decent dumb I mean my bishop he is
on a dark square is his I've got the
potentially better Bishop him maybe he
wants to take play rogue f7 let's do
that
and night there won't be six that's
really a debatable piece yeah sometimes
not see what could be good but and okay
so he closes down the whole thing maybe
I should have gone to have it
interesting if I go if I take them
that's very if it's a very funny way to
play and let's do that I have night a82
shield c7 for most purposes and I have I
want to go look g6 route g8 and trying
to reroute the knight to c6 funny funny
position yeah I'm not sure about that my
whole plan here if this was any good I
let's see i can trade one rookie now
with rook c8 my problem is that there
are H pawns that's really the big issue
in a in a heavy piece and game or in a
in a sorry in a minor PSN game he might
have you can approach with the king and
get the h5 pond I think this would be
quite okay if there weren't any age
pawns but with the edge pawns I really
don't know it looks funky
can I do yeah this is exactly the issue
trading now is it's not going to work
taking g for Butchie seven-time morning
can do that
they are completely busted that's
completely busted absolutely nothing I
can do in king of Seven Kings 26 chair
can do you will just play look somewhere
and then push the pawn rook c7 is even
more precise chair now I cannot even
play this this move chap black resins
and check the puzzle bad game yeah okay
but what did I do wrong there it's kind
of curious and so we had this and I went
and took and went here is this really so
bad I really don't believe it okay look
here six I mean there are interesting
things along along the way that this is
really interesting maybe it's really
just wrong to take that's possible
I think it's wrong it's wrong to take
its really wrong this is pretty much
leading to the game meds it's very I
mean it's very difficult to avoid us
what I'm trying to say this is what
happened here I mean I can definitely
play better but let's see I say a way to
this losing up and nicely played there
with ruchi sorry this group g2 this is a
this is far too ambitious there maybe I
can still kind of I can try to play that
but he will do this right I can never
take myself that's just rubbish that's
probably just not any good so Bishop
takes the follows a mistake there yeah
one problem is that he also has this
move I'm sorry not to a five he has this
idea which is the problem yeah i played
this a plate this really badly Knight b6
not be 6 wasn't a good idea what I
should do is probably play something
like this and be ready to answer an f4
with age 5 and this is definitely okay I
mean f4 is actually I think a mistake if
I'm ready to block f4 as a mistake i can
i can jump there late him he has to play
something slowish now i don't know what
exactly
yeah this is okay and about equal maybe
comp gives like a slight edge but not
sure about that it was equal don't want
to be too optimistic there but it's
definitely better than what I did I mean
this is yeah he can get an f5 and this
is not good really not sure the comp
wants to do this it's an interesting way
to claim maybe that's better actually
because here I'm I have ideas to take
and get rid of the H pawn check in this
situation if he takes I can take with
the pawn and I'm glad that there's no f6
coming and if he goes f6 this is less
problematic now because I will be able
to trade there or I mean in case of
capturing this is really bad interesting
that's interesting keeping this tension
on this much better mmm that's
remarkable Chad's really much better
than the game
yeah only later Rooney understood that
having those aged pawns as a huge
disadvantage because it is so
disconnected from my camp the h5 pawn
okay well thanks for watching